اضافي
ومن المامول من قطر الان يعني بعد اطاله
امد
الحرب شكرا سليمان اولا يعني ودعني اجيب
يعني باجابه عامه على ما تفضلت به بلا شك
انه منذ اليوم الاول لهذه الماساه حقيقه
وهذه التطورات الخطيره اقليميا ودوليا كان
الموقف القطري واضح انه يجب ان يتم احتواء
هذه الازمه باسرع وقت ممكن التسرب
الاقليمي لهذه الازمه والتوسع الاقليمي
لهذه الازمه لن يكون له من اثر الا مزيد
من التوتر على مستوى الاقليم ودوليا ولذلك
عملت قطر منذ اليوم الاول في جهود الوساطه
بالتواصل ليس فقط مع طرفي النزاع ولكن مع
الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه المختلفه
وشاهدت كيف ان الجهود القطريه لم تتوقف في
احلك الاوقات بما في ذلك ما يجري في هذه
الايام سواء من خلال الاتصالات او
الزيارات او المبادرات التي قدمت في اطار
انهاء هذه الحرب ونحن نعتقد يقينا بان كل
هذه التوترات الاقليميه التي ذكرتها هي
فرع من اصل والاصل هو ايقاف هذه الحرب
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان نتحدث عن حل لكل هذه
التوترات اذا تجاهلنا وضع الحرب في غزه
المجتمع الدولي مطالب اليوم اذا كان هناك
رغبه حقيقيه في ان لا يكون هناك توترات
اقليميه على مستوى ما يحدث في البحر
الاحمر او ما يحدث في العراق او ما يحدث
في غيرها من المواقع اقليميا مطالب بان
يتخذ قرارا واضحا في الضغط لايقاف هذه
الحرب فورا وليس الحديث عن تمكين لاستمرار
هذه الحرب من خلال ا الغاء انسانيه
الفلسطيني وتحويل هذه المساله لمساله يعني
لا يمكن التعامل معها الا من خلال هذه
الصوره التي نراها اليوم على الشاشات من
القتل والدمار اليومي الذي يستهدف
انسانيتنا جميعا وبالتالي الحديث حقيقه عن
كل ما يحدث في المنطقه كما قال معالي لا
شك ان ما يحدث في البحر الاحمر يمثل خطوره
على الملاحه الدوليه ويمثل قلق بالنسبه
لكل الدول التي تعتمد على خطوط الملاحه
هذه وقطر من الدول التي تعتمد عليها بشكل
كبير جدا طبعا في صادراتها من من قطاع
الطاقه وفي وارداتها من العالم كله ولكن
لا يمكن التعامل مع هذه المساله كانها
منفصله تماما وبشكل معزول تماما عن الحرب
في في غزه وتطوراتها العمل يجب ان ينصب
هناك توسع في الحلول الامنيه ايضا هو
مشكله كما قال معاليه في جلسته اليوم في
في دافس هذه المساله لن تحل بشكل عسكري
امني هي ستحل بشكل سياسي من خلال ايقاف
الحرب في في غزه وبقيه هذه التداعيات
ستتراجع بنا على ذلك تستمر الجهود القطريه
هذه الايام من خلال الاتصالات مع مختلف
الاطراف نحن على امل ان يكون هناك تقدم في
هذه المفاوضات في الايام القادمه الوضع
كما تعلمون هو صعب بشكل كبير هناك جزئيات
يتم التفاوض عنها حاليا الان على امل ان
يكون هناك تطورات ايجابيه وستعلن عنا ان
شاء الله في حال كلله هذه المحاولات بنجاح
انور السلام عليكم عندي سؤال اول بالنسبه
للنقل في البحر الاحمر في معلومات انه
استانفت قطر تسير الناقلات الغاز هل
تستطيع ان تؤكد لنا انه تم استئناف الخمس
ناقلات اللي كانت متوقفه استانفت اي العمل
او البحار في البحر الاحمر هذا السؤال
الاول السؤال الثاني كان هناك في معلومات
الاسبوع الماضي تتحدث عن مبادره قطريه
باطار المفاوضات تتعلق بادخال الادويه
للاسرى الفلس الاسرائيليين عنما مقابل
ادخال ادويه للفلسطينيين في مستشفيات هل
تمت هذه المبادره انجزت يعني او الى وصلت
اذا لم ت تنجز حتى الان شكرا شكرا انور
بالنسبه لناقلات الغاز لا يمكني حقيقه
تاكيد هذه المعلومات واتركها للجهات
المختصه في في قطر للطاقه و ولديهم اكيد
المعلومات التفصيليه بهذا الشان بالنسبه
لسؤالك الثاني كما تعلمون هذه التقارير
تحدثت عن وجود هذه المفاوضات نعم هذه
المفاوضات هي قائمه وال العمل جاري مع
جميع الاط اطراف لم يتم شيء حتى الان فيما
يتعلق بتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق او الوصول الى
الى الاتفاق ونحن على امل ان يكون هناك
تطورات ايجابيه فيه ولكن لا يوجد لدينا اي
اي تحديث فيما يتعلق بهذا بهذا الامر لم
يتم ادخال الادويه بعد حت هذ
اللحظه
تفضل في الاسبوع الماضي ايضا تم تداول
معلومات على ان قطر اقترحت
خطه تشمل هذه الخطه وقف الحرب مقابل اخراج
حماس من قطاع الى اي مدى هذا الكلام صحيح
وهذا الكلام نقلا عن ما طبعا نعم احن قلنا
بوضوح في مواجهه هذه الاخبار اولا دعني
اؤكد يعني بكل وضوح ان كل هذه التسريبات
والمعلومات المغلوطه التي تنشر في وسائل
الاعلام من قبل جهات مختلفه ليس لها من
هدف الا تخريب جهد المفاوضات على الارض
وبلا شك ان قطر لم تكن طرفا في مثل هذه
الفكره كما طرحت في هذه التقارير قطر منذ
اليوم الاول كانت تبحث عن كلكل الفرص
الممكنه في عمليه التفاوض لتحقيق اتفاق
ولكن ليس هناك
حسب اطلاعنا في في قطر اي اشاره لهذه
المساله بهذا الشكل ونؤكد مره اخرى على ان
مثل هذه التسريبات ليس لها من هدف الا
تخريب المسار التفاوضي وهذا ما يجب ان
يكون يعني هناك حذر كبير بشانه خاصه في
وسائل الاعلام ولد المسؤولين الذين يعلقون
على مثل هذه التصريحات العمليه التفاوضيه
عمليه عمليه حساسه وهي تجري في اصعب
الظروف حاليا ويجب ان يترك لها مساحه لان
تنجح وتحقق الهدف الاساسي الذي هو ايقاف
هذه
الحرب محمد القاز
مباشر تحدث عن مؤشر ايجا الوصول الى اتفاق
لكن المتابع
لتصريحات تصريحات متصلبه في
الحقيقه لا توحي باي امل لعوده الى اتفاق
يعني فهل يعني بالمكان ان تضعنا في هذه
المؤشرات يعني الى اي مدى هذه المؤشرات
الايجابيه كذلك هل ما زالت جهود الوساطه
منصبه فقط على غزا ام انها اتسعت مع اتساع
دائره الحرب سواء في البحر الاحمر او في
الفه الغربيه او في جنوب لبنان السؤال
الثاني اسال عن المساعدات التي تصل الى
مدينه العريش هل تنتقل هذه المساعدات الى
قطاع زا بكل سلاسه انها ما زالت او معظم
هذه مساعدات في
المطار طيب اولا بالنسبه
لتصريحات رئيس وزراء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في ما يمكن ان نقول هنا بوضوح انحنا
معنيين بالمسار التفاوضي نفسه وب عمليه
التفاوض نفسها الان هناك الكثير من
الرسائل السياسيه والدعائي التي تقال على
مثل هذه المنصات ولكن اقول لكم بوضوح ان
الجهد مستمر الاطراف ما زالت منخرط في
العمليه التفاوضيه ونحن معنيين اكثر بما
يجري في قاعه التفاوض وليس ما يجري في
وسائل الاعلام بالنسبه ل
جود الوساطه التي تجري حاليا طبعا هناك
الكثير
من العمل الذي يجري على مستوى ايقاف الحرب
في غزه لقناعتنا الاساسيه بان حل هذه
الازمه يبدا بايقاف الحرب وبالتالي الحديث
عن بقيه الامور هي فرع من الحديث عن ايقاف
الحرب حاليا ليس هناك وساطه مباشره تقودها
قطر في غير هذا الملف تحديدا وفي ملف
ايقاف الحق وذلك اساسا لقناعتنا بان كلكل
هذه القضايا هي قضايا يعني ستنتهي او يمكن
التعامل معها او يمكن احتوائها في حال تم
ايقاف هذه الحرب ولكن اذا لم يتم ايقاف
هذه الحرب واستمرت اله الحرب الاسرائيليه
في في طحن المواطن الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه
فلن ينتج عن ذلك الا مزيد من التداعيات
الاقليميه بالنسبه للمساعدات التي تصل الى
مدينه العريش هناك تنسيق كامل مع الاشقاء
في جمهوريه مصر العربيه ومنظمه الامم
المتحده بلا شك في ظل الوضع الامني في
قطاع غزه وممارسات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
في القطاع تستمر الصعوبات التي تواجه دخول
هذه المساعدات الى القطاع نحن نسعى بقدر
الامكان على ان يدخل اكبر قدر ممكن من
المساعدات التي تصل الى العريش قطاع غزه
هناك تحديات لوجستيه هناك تحديات امنيه
هناك تحديات مرتبطه بالاجراءات وغير ذلك
ولكن ما يمكن ان نؤكد عليه هو اننا نستمر
في ايصال هذه المساعدات وكثير منها يدخل
طبعا الى قطاع غزه بشكل متتابع ليس لدي
ارقام طبعا حول المساعدات التي دخلت ولكن
ما يمكن ان نؤكد ان عمليه دخول هذه
المساعدات مستمر ولو بشكل
جزئي
احمد في لقاء رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري في مؤتمر دافس ذكر ان
هناك مقترحات قدمت من قبل القاده العرب
فيما يخص وقف اطلاق النار في غزه ولكنها
قبلت بالرفض هل يمكن بايجاز اعطائنا عن
فكره عن هذه المبادرات هذا السؤال الاول
السؤال الثاني يتعلق بالبحر الاحمر هل
هناك خط مباشر خط تفاوضي مباشر بين
السلطات القطريه وبين الحوثيين هل هناك خط
لايقاف الهجوم الحوثي في البحر الاحمر هل
هناك خط متواصل بين بين قطر وبين الحوثيين
شكرا شكرا احمد بالنسبه للمبادرات العربيه
انا اعتقد معالي كان يشير الى تاريخ
القضيه الفلسطينيه بشكل عام وال المبادرات
العربيه التي قدمت لتحقيق السلام والوصول
الى حل عادل للقضيه ال ينيه بشكل عام وليس
تحديدا طبعا في هذه الازمه لكن مع ذلك في
هناك الكثير من المبادرات والافكار التي
طرحت هذا مسار تفاوضي في ظل حرب فبالتالي
من الطبيعي ان يكون هناك الكثير من
المبادرات اللي تطرح ويتم اعاده التفكير
فيها واعاده صياغتها بشكل يتناسب مع
تطورات الوضع الميداني بالنسبه ل ما يجري
في البحر الاحمر نحن نؤكد ان حاليا لا
يوجد لدينا اي جهد خاص تفاوضي في هذا
الاطار
وا اصدرنا يعني موقفنا بوضو وضوح او اعلنا
موقفنا بوضوح باننا نرى ان هذه المساله هي
خطيره جدا على الملاح العالميه ولكن يجب
التعامل مع المساله المركزيه وهي ايقاف
الحرب في في قطاع غزه اولا وكما اكد معالي
طبعا في الجلسه الحلول العسكريه لم تاتي
في اي في اي حاله من هذه الحالات بنتيجه
ايجابيه وبالتالي يجب ان يتم التعامل
السياسي مع هذا الامر قبل ان يتفاقم
اكثر نحدث عن عنبوره اخرى من النزاع وعني
به السودان ا كان من المفترض ان يلتقي
البرهان و ومجموعه الايجاد خلال اليومين
القادمين ولكن الحكومه السودانيه رفضت
لعدم التزام الجن جويده والدعم السريع
بالمخرجات اتفاق جده هل هناك اي جهود
قطريه حاليا جاريه فيما يتعلق بالتعاون مع
الاتحاد الافريقي او الايجاد لايجاد حل
سياسي في السودان خاصه ان الامور تتدور
واكثر من 7 مليون تركوا وهاجر او نزحوا
داخليا او خارجيا شكرا نعم بالنسبه للوضع
في السودان الشقيق كان موقف دوله قطر منذ
اليوم الاول ضروره توقف هذه الحرب وهذه
المواجهات التي لا تعود الا بمزيد من
المعاناه على الشعب السوداني الشقيق ودعم
دوله قطر عبر البيانات المختلفه جهود
الوساطه الاقليميه والدوليه التي تمت
لانهاء
هذه الحرب وحقيقه ان نحن ننظر بالكثير من
الاسى والكثير من الالم لما يحدث في
السودان الشقيق هذه الدوله التي نتمتع
معها طبعا بعلاقات عميقه على مختلف
المستويات ولذلك نتمنى ان نرى نهايه لهذه
الازمه قريبا ليس هناك حاليا جهود خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالوساطه في هذا الملف ولكن
كما تعلمون الاتصالات جاريه مع مختلف
الاطراف اقليميا ودوليا
للتعامل مع هذا الملف بالشكل الامثل وكما
تفضلت بطريقه تضمن ان يكون هناك حل سياسي
ينهي هذه
الازمه في سؤال
اخر
اعذرون لم احضر احاطه منذ بدايتها ولم
اعرف ما طرح من اسئله وما لم يطرح اعطينا
فكره عن استئناف شاحنات نقل الغاز القطريه
عبر البحر
الاحمر وعلى حد فهمي ان قطر في انتظار بعض
التحديثات الامنيه هل قطر قادره على
التواصل مع الحوثي بهذا الصدد للحصول على
تاكيدات بشان امن سفنا شكرا
كارن ليس لدي تحديث حول
الوضع الحالي لناقلات الغاز القطريه وسواء
سيتم مرورها عبر البحر الاحمر ام هناك لا
ولكن على يقين اننا نعمل مع الشركاء
الدوليين والاقليمي لضمان
ان جميع شحناتنا الصادره والوارده
بالحمايه والامن والامان وكما قال سعادته
صباح اليوم في جلسه دافس ان هذا يشكل خطرا
كبيرا على الملاحه البحريه العالميه وال
الاقليميه وما يحدث في البحر الاحمر الا
انه ياتي جزءا يتجزا من الازمه في غزه
وانهاء الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه وهذا
بهذه الطريقه يجب ان نتصدى لهذه المساله
وكما
اجبت على سؤال زميلك من قبل اطلب منك ان
تتوجه الى قطر للطاقه للاستفسار بشكل محدد
عن رحلات نقلات الغاز ولكن من
الواضح مع استمرار الهجمات في البحر
الاحمر هذه قضيه امنيه تشكل تهديدا كبيرا
للمنطقه وال التصعيد الذي يجري
هناك يبدو ملحا يجعلنا اكثر صرامه لبحث عن
حل للقضيه الاساسيه كما قال سعادته صباح
اليوم ان الحل
العسكري لن ياتي بالامن ل البحر الاحمر
يجب ان نتعامل مع هذا بطريقه سياسيه
دبلوماسيه وهو انهاء الوضع في غزه على
الفور انا خالد الطوالبه قطار تريبيون
دكتور نعتقد انه قطر حاليا يعني هي الدوله
الوحيده
اي او خلينا نتكلم
هي يعني من اهم الدول اللي بتشتغل حاليا
عالميا على ايقاف التهجير وايقاف الحرب في
غزه شو هي التحديات اللي بتواجهك حاليا في
غزه وهل جهود قطر لايقاف الحرب حاليا يعني
بتلاحظوا انها يعني اتت ثمار هل في نتائج
ملموسه على الارض اي هل في استجابه دوليه
واقليميه اي كمان سؤال ثاني دكتور بالنسبه
ل العمليات العسكريه في اليمن ما هو موقف
قطر الرسمي من العمليات العسكريه في اليمن
و وهل يعني هل تعتقدون انه لها علاقه بما
يحصل في غزه فعليا كما هو معلن ام ام انها
عمليات منفصله تماما وشكرا
شكرا اولا بالنسبه للتحديات بلا شك ان
هناك تحديات كبيره على راسها طبعا هو
التصعيد العسكري الجاري على الارض وحجم
الاستهداف اليومي للمدنيين والمنشات
المدنيه في قطاع غزه وهو بلا شك يعقد اي
جهد لمفاوضات تقود اي اي جهه بما في ذلك
طبعا الجهود اللي تقودها دوله قطر التصعيد
خارج اطار غزه ايضا سواء في الضفه او في
جنوب لبنان ا او غير ذلك هو بلا شك ايضا
من التحديات الكبرى التي تواجهها جهود
الوساطه القطريه والاضافه الى ذلك طبعا
تسييس المواقف من هذه الحرب ليس فقط على
مستوى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وفلسطين لكن
ايضا على مستوى الدول الاخرى التي ترتبط ب
دوره انتخابيه تجعل من مواقفها مرهونه
بهذه الدوره الانتخابيه وما رايناه في ذلك
طبعا من احيانا مواقف متراجعه عن المطالبه
بايقاف هذه الحرب في في غزه بسبب هذا
التاثير على الدوره الانتخابيه وهذا امر
حقيقه نحن ندعو القاده في في العالم
والدول المختلفه في العالم الى ان تتخذ
موقفا واضحا جدا من انهاء هذه الحرب فورا
دون الاعتبارات السياسيه المحليه نحن الان
نقف امام تحدي يواجه انسانيتنا جميعا لا ي
يمكن ان نستعرض هذا التحدي في ظل ان
الحسابات هي حسابات محليه ضيقه بالنسبه
للموقف الرسمي مما جرى في اليمن اعتقد ان
تصريحات معالي صباح هذا اليوم كانت واضحه
الحديث هنا عن حل عسكري عن لهذه التحديات
في البحر الاحمر لن يؤي وكل كل هذه
التصعيدات في المنطقه هي تصعيدات فرعيه في
مواجهه التصعيد الرئيسي في قطاع غزه ونحن
لدينا ثقه كامله بانه في حال انهيت هذه
الحرب في قطاع غزه في حال انتهت هذه
الماساه في قطاع غزه سيمكن ذلك من خفض
التصعيد في الاقليم بشكل عام يعني دكتور
انا اسف بس نكمل السؤال بس النقطه الاخيره
تعتقد انه هو امتداد لما يحصل في غزه ام
انه بعيد تماما عنه منصل العمليات
العسكريه هذه التحديات الاقليميه و حالات
التصعيد الاقليميه التي تجري بلا شك هي
مرتبطه بالتصعيد الاساسي في قطاع غزه لا
يمكننا حقيقه تاكيد يعني النوايا خلف
هذه التحركات اقليميا ولكن ما يمكن ان
نؤكده هو انه لم توجد هذه التحديات على
الارض لم توجد حالات تصعيد هذه على الارض
الا في ظل هذه الحرب على قطاع غزه يعني
اين هذا التصعيد قبل الحرب على غزه لم يكن
موجودا لا في العراق ولا في ولا في اليمن
ولا في غيرها وبالتالي وجودها الان هو بحد
ذاته دلاله على انها ترتبط بهذه الحرب
وهذا التصعيد الاقليمي بشكل عام في قطاع
غز سؤال اخر طيب يعطيكم العافيه نلتقي
الاسبوع القادم ان شاء الله